le réflexe crémastérien votre vie
sexuelle souffre de la routine vous
trouvez vos organes génitaux et ceux de
votre partenaire bien ennuyeux j'ai un
petit jeu pour vous effleuré
délicatement d'un doigt l'intérieur de
la cuisse la vôtre ou celle d'une
personne consentante juste là vous
observerez le testicule ou la grande
lève du même côté c'est le V par la
magie du muscle crémastère qui se
contracte en faisant en alternance le
même mouvement de chaque côté vous
pouvez ainsi jouer au marionnettes
ça sert pas qu'à s'amuser les médecins
s'en servent aussi pour vérifier qu'on a
pas une torsion testiculaire parce que
classiquement si c'est le cas le réflexe
disparaît ça fait mal et en plus c'est
une urgence vous pouvez aussi obtenir
une réaction très satisfaisante avec une
légère stimulation scrotale en en romain
stimulation scrotal ça veut dire
gratouiller le scrotum la peau des
testicules lui je te déconseille d'aller
jouer avec ses robinets la stimulation
va entraîner une rétractation réflexe du
scrotum un petit peu comme avec les
escargots et avec cette texture un peu
peau d'éléphant qu'on les testicules ça
donne un effet absolument hilarant qui
va réjouir toute l'assemblée